a few gauge drops to the car when I'm
sitting my legs I checked up the floor
that's in the face and I walked along my
mother's Street laughing
because I never got my neck I met loads
and loads of women that were in prison
and done lots of different crimes but I
never ever met another girl that just
armed robberies all the windows started
coming through Bam Bam all the guns were
out I'm seeing old Bill standing
everywhere I actually thought he was
going to walk off
and he just walked up to me and he just
ran bang bang straight in the end
thank you
this child is like my childhood was just
feral it was just a normal average
childhood being brought up beaten bad
abused neglected and abandoned really so
with opening fridges and cupboards and
there's no food getting bread out of
things all moldy thinking well I can't
remember why can't my mum be like
everybody else why can't we be like
everybody else there's mounds of drugs
there's 20 30 people in my house doing
packaging up gear packaging up money
like these are things I see as a baby
right so I know everyone's crooked I
know my dad's dodgy I've seen guns in my
ass like we're not stupid no I know my
dad's no good and my mum's always higher
I used to go shopping my mum fill up a
bag and it's all right go and wait
outside me I'll be out in a minute and
you know what they're doing and I just
thought everyone done this shoplifting
and feeding so I've been caught
shoplifting by a store detective they've
took me home to my dad my dad's punched
me in the face dragged me in the house
he gives him God I may make calm down
calm down and I remember him saying calm
down foreign
and just turned on the [ __ ] fire the
gas fire and then just burnt my hand
like
and I'm thinking
I love you you love me why are you
burning my hand like what are you doing
like why Dad Dad please please please in
my head I'm screaming screaming
screaming physically I'm screaming
please Dad please that he's burning I
can smell it you can see it and I'm
thinking wow and then he beat me with a
belt and then he took me back into the
kitchen and made me heat two massive
spoons would be kind of hot pepper sauce
and told me if I have a fever again will
begin twice as much and I went in my
bedroom that night and I cried and I
sobbed and I thought why would my dad do
that to me like why would my dad do that
to me huh why would you do that to me I
just this is
right [ __ ] show you I'll show you and
that was it from that point I just I had
no respect for anybody after that point
like that was eight years of age I just
grew up with a real deep hatred towards
anything can everybody
my mom was good my stepdad weren't so
good my my real dad he was terrible he
slit his throat when I was one I became
very angry very
very
um dysfunctional as a child and I've
come out of care absolutely clueless I
don't know how to read I don't know how
to write I don't know how to pay bills I
don't know how to drive properly I could
drive because I've known how to steep
cars but the only thing I could put my
hands to was was crime I went from being
a small time criminal to progressing to
progressing so you could just imagine
this you start off small and you
progress basically bit by bit going
through the criminal world going bigger
and bigger and bigger
where my childhood was a came to a
working class family
and uh I get boss still at 16 stealing
cars shortlifting it was just a life of
cream for me
and I started the robbing post office
people
and a security guards we used to just
steal cars and the Jeweler shops were
opened to draw right outside them and
they sledgehammed them and take them
away and as as the years would own the
the offending just get more serious
I grew up in the East End of London
um I had a very happy childhood we were
not very rich
as was most of the people in the East
End and it wasn't until I met my
then to be first husband that I actually
ever got involved in crime him and his
friends they used to rob banks
security vans
post offices he would sit and plot his
jobs with his friends
and he said to me I'm going to work on
Friday which meant you would be doing an
armed robbery
it sounds strange and
I don't know I've always said that when
I was told that he was shot something
happened to my brain I decided I would
become a bank robber and I would take
over
from what he did and I became the boss
of the Gang
when did you start then dabbling in
criminal activity
my dad would have my house you have my
mom's house and in the front room there
would be a mound of weed and they put me
little in little packs and then packs
were going to black bags and then
basically what ice and nickel so my
dad's come back to my mum's he knows the
I know it's you and he's beating my mum
beating my mum and I was like
and he was obeying it I've got a big
bang in my one so I've picked the paint
I said I've got a [ __ ] bank I'll run
down the stairs I've run it through the
kitchen door and put the blades watches
now she's [ __ ] touch her again I'll
kill you
and then my mom was like son so I said
no he can't come back here and then he's
gone never said a word and when and
that's me becoming a man
can you just list off some of the things
you were doing what were the kind of
activities you were on board I've been
under investigation I think for
24.
24 murders
um seven or eight showings
and maybe
30 40 armed robberies
I got arrested for Lots I got punished
for lots and I got away with lots
how can we rob a bank in broad daylight
without any weapons without any one
question in US so we thought well
burgers burgers is the best way because
you're completely covered from head to
toe you can't see your face you can wear
gloves and you can blend into any
situation like you're in London streets
and it only takes a second to pull that
disguise off and you're back in civilian
clothes
so we've gone to Regents Park Mosque and
I've gone into the clothing section and
there was a load of Muslim women in
there as well as everybody else and I'm
I'm trying on these dresses me and Nick
are trying them on and I'm looking at
Nick's looking at me he's like yeah you
look good I'm like yeah you look good
and then from there we just we decided
right let's go let's let's do this so
then we've gone to Kilburn high road and
that's when we've robbed the bank
literally about an hour later and it was
just by luck for us that day there was
uh there was a couple of Muslim people
actually in the bank genuine Muslim
ladies and they were fully dressed in
burkas as well so we've sort of blended
into these this little crowd of people
yeah so we're in the bank and we're
moving forward with the queue and the
next thing
um the security guard that's carrying
the money to and from the bank is right
beside me now and right beside the shoot
is where he puts the money in as he's
done that I've grabbed him and I've
flung him across the bank
I had the mentality that I was
Untouchable I thought I was I generally
thought I was I thought I was better
than the police and my lifestyle then
became
more erratic
my friend was on your own food shorts
and he came up to see me where he was
still on the run and he presented me
says but would you like to been in this
robbery and this is a
you can be the driver so I just went a
man there was no there was no alarms at
the time when on the floors of the main
bank and the vote was at the back
I think it was about 15 16 a staff
was in money where's the key that blah
blah blah my friends they get Sicky
everybody they were passing they passed
from going oh he's at the keys so the
gun just get blasted into the ceiling
and then a plaster came down from the
heads
but the story
since then
Scottish press they keep saying
somebody's been a girl was shot in the
head but it's just as bad to tell you
the truth because it was traumatized and
I told you I apologized here anyway are
you serious I wouldn't do that but I
could imagine they are mental state
after that no I mean so I've done 10
years
five months five weeks
yeah five days and five seconds you came
out oh you did this party because it was
it performs the edger system and say
well I'm not feeling about I'm getting
straight back into seeing this crane
how did it feel like to be a female
gangster did male gangster street views
differently
um
I think they did they they all respected
me
and I actually gradually did become the
boss and everything was put by me should
we do this should we do that I met loads
and loads of women that were in prison
and done lots of different crimes
um but I never ever met another girl
that jadan robberies is that true that
you've met cray Brothers
I met reg I used to speak to him every
week for half an hour
and he used to send me flowers and
little gifts
and he actually proposed to me twice
what did you tell him I said no I didn't
think it was a very good idea forever of
us and he said no I guess not but I
think we would have gone well inevitably
in the end you do get caught because the
odds go against you as time goes on
and I was arrested
and I got seven years from robbery which
was
I had the biggest sentence in Holloway
prison
what's the closest you've been to
death
I should have a driver used to drive me
about everywhere I've got my mate's
house he's got a load of watches marvs
you want this one I said now my wife for
watching a minute so my driver said I
want one can I get one so my mate said
is he all right I said yeah he sweets a
lot I pay his wages
get him over once about a month later my
mate's rung me up and said hello
Marvel's happening son I said I'm all
right mate you he said yeah he said I'm
a little bit disappointed mom I said why
is that
he said that I was just wondering if
you're going to be paying for that watch
anytime soon
why did he pay for that
cheeky
hello mate listen you need to go around
and pay without watching my eyes and
punch you off go and pay for the watch
what's the matter with you he said he's
got nothing to do with you why are you
getting involved I said why are you
little where are you where are you I
said I'm Dan Paul bunus I said I'll be
down in a minute so I've jumped into my
flu down here as I pulled up he's come
walking up so I've seen him off jump so
I said coming in let's go mate well he's
like
he shot me again I was like what have
you got to do with that I didn't believe
he would show me so I thought as long as
I can get close to him well I'll just
smash his [ __ ] alien and shoot and I
took two steps and he shot me in this
leg and as he shot me in his leg it just
disintegrated and he walks over me he's
done me again and then he's done me
again I actually thought he was gonna
walk off
and I'll see him look at me
and he he had a full
and now I know what the fall was
he said this is going to kill me I've
got to kill him and he just walked up to
me and he just ran bang bang straight in
the head by the first one as Mead's gone
bad for oh my God this just shot me in
the face I can't believe it I'm gonna
die
and I've opened my eye and I thought wow
and I'll see the barrel with a gun and I
thought what the [ __ ] and then I'll just
see the bullet coming towards me and
that's when I've heard the bang and then
I've heard footsteps running off and I
was like
gone like that my knob is just
splattered all over my pants like my leg
now there's no blood like it's in blood
but it was just all fleshy like
everything was just flesh open and I was
like Wow I'll try to ring an ambulance
what's happened I said I've been shot or
once in the leg once in my groin once in
my arm and twice in my head
silence
hung up
hello hello hello I've done this three
times before the police had to ring them
back and say no no it's true it's true
it's true
and then something serious to somebody
who I wouldn't name they were called the
new kids in the block
when I went to Pleasant and I came out
they really haven't done it fairly
accurate for it so it even the new kids
in the block and I had to run in one
night the track gets tricky to me
before I was an old man
it was freezing the name for me
uh 2009
and uh
then flooded the player of the Tuesday
a few guys dropped to a car
and I thought one of them popped me in
the head there were amateurs so it was
me out of just
done whatever I'm in for my younger days
so anyway we have rent flying and the
light come on you're supposed to be a
gangster
and then
the world just brought knives up but it
was just from the corner from my
mother's house I've never run away in my
life I was 47 48 and then
and I could have only around 200 yards
and then another I started fighting with
them but they got me Ironically in a
church gate at my mother's house
when I'm sitting my legs I checked up my
throat that's in my face she can see
I've got a scar it's called the Mars Bar
in Glasgow
and that's me quite being but that
scared doesn't bothering me but to tell
you truth the scada is really bad they
had to get through plastic surgery it
was hanging out and I walked along my
mother's Street laughing
because I never got my neck
I was full of hate I hated to it like I
hated the place I hated the world that I
lived in I hated everyone I literally
generally hated everybody
um obviously I was taking alcohol I was
taking drugs at that time in my life
because
that was the lifestyle unfortunately
someone else had then informed me that
they're nowhere
um they know where our property property
developer lives that has large
quantities of Jewelry in their house so
we've gone we've traveled to radlett
Hertfordshire and I sat outside this
house for four or five hours waiting for
this person to come back the ladies come
back she pulled up her big metal gates
have opened up at the front of her house
the big Gates have closed behind her
she's Drive the silver Mercedes
convertible Mercedes into the house and
I was
I was just concentrating on the money I
wasn't caring about the victim I weren't
thinking about how I was going to make
her feel or the effects that I would
have on her life what's happened to her
is she's been put on the floor
and all her jewelry was removed the
feder and then on the spot watches Rings
bracelets necklaces earrings and stuff
like that which is bad mate and I hate
even talking about this
um and I remember the her face was well
I can't explain it it was horrible but
um it just started I I thought nah mate
so I've run I left the building I've
grabbed my legs and we've run
I've run got in the car
drive off
next thing
a big whack has come from the left-hand
side of the car and all I can see is
guys jumping out of cars pulling out
guns and putting caps on and obviously I
knew straight away it was flying Squad
as the police next thing another police
cars crashed into the side of this car a
car's pulled up in front all the windows
started coming through Bam Bam all the
guns were out I'm seeing old bills
standing everywhere pointing machine
um handguns at me we get rested we go to
the police station and we start getting
all our case papers our depths they're
called all our paperwork starts coming
through and in the paperwork it's got a
thing called an impact statement
um now this this impact statement is the
impact of your offense that what the
offense you've committed on that person
the impact of that crime and in her
statement
um she explained how she felt she felt
afraid obviously she felt I think she
wrote but what changed me and changed my
whole outlook on crime and outlook on
absolutely everything was the fact that
when she was being robbed she got turned
over
she got turned over so we could control
her but she at that point she thought
she was going to be raped which makes me
feel disgusting make I never woke up
decided that I want to be a thug today
it was a lifestyle that was pushed upon
me you know I mean and that's not an
excuse it's just the way it was
what was the prison life like some
prisons were really hard
there's a lot of bullying
there's a lot of stealing off each other
there's there's a it's like a a world in
miniature I suppose in one way I was
lucky because
um when I went to prison the first time
as were the men who went to prison the
bank robbers were looked on as the
hierarchy that everyone in the prison
looked up to
I suppose I actually got that same from
when I went into prison the first time
and it was sort of like oh wow she's the
Armed robber she's the and it did good
for me if that makes sense
that the girls all respected me and I
never got bullied I never got picked on
I always got treated with the utmost
respect from all the girls the famous
quite famously call you Black Widow yes
I don't take myself seriously and I
think okay I'm the Black Widow you would
have called me the Black Widow do I care
it doesn't matter you're 60 now this is
all behind you
what's next what's in the future for you
how do you see everything the ABD
would it would be great to have some
money in all that but it's not the Bo on
the end all everything the thing is
I'm glads I'm still alive I didn't
expect to see 50 or 60.
so every day is a bonus
you've turned your life around or not
like you've gone you're you're trying to
help people and all this no no I'm not
trying to help you I'm helping everybody
like I'm helping everybody out come into
contact with me there's no trying I'm
an advocate against Crime a mentor peer
mentor motivational speaker personal
trainer personal coach and life speaking
life coach we're going to schools
colleges and prisons and I just sort of
ask the kids for what what are you doing
why are you doing it where's your role
where's you're going where's your goal
like what's your objective
I look back now
and don't recognize that person
I really don't and it's so alien to me
but
I sort of am shocked at myself to think
that I actually was that person and did
do the things I did
and there is a deep regret on that
did you ever meet the woman who had the
impact on you no I haven't but every
single podcast I go and I say sorry like
I say sorry on these ones I do more
because I hope to meet her one day and I
hope to meet her I hope to hold her hand
and say sorry if she does ever watch
these things she'll see
that is that there's a genuine man in
front of the camera that he is sorry for
the things he's done you know it
generally is and he's he's trying to
make make the world better now
you're in a happy place I may I'm I'm
listen I'm happy
when I get mail
right I'm happy that I'm registered at
her house I'm happy that I'll get Mao
I'm happy that I'll pay taxes I'm happy
that I'm going to leave here get in my
car and I'm gonna drive and I don't have
to worry about blue lights when I hear a
siren I don't even look anymore do you
understand like I've got I'm free I'm
free I'm free and there is no better
feeling on this planet than being free
that lad
wasn't on that Wing very long he went to
the gym one day someone found out what
he'd done
um I remember the lad and he hit him
with a dumbbell
in the face he went to hospital and I
never saw him again